c'est tout de même étrange si nous
demandons à monsieur du snob il est
peut-être au courant mais non je les
rencontre il y en à peine un quart
d'heure il n'avait pas vu casimir depuis
que celui ci a quitté les jardins pour
la dernière fois voilà nous amis
toujours bonjour vous n'auriez pas vu
casimir par hasard ne savons absolument
pas où il est passé
non c'est bien dommage écoute françois
je l'entends et oui c'est bien lui tout
un hors jeu
sinon maggie maladroit ce n'est pas ma
faute à moi
il a l'air de très bonne humeur je
préfère ça cela prouve qu'il lui est
rien arrivé non btan parents parents
pourquoi pas bonjour du juge salut
françois salut quasiment bonjour
d'eysines et tu as l'air de tenir la
forme des grands jours
ça va très bien et qu'est ce qui te rend
si joyeux c'est la satisfaction du
travail bien fait c'est en effet une
bonne raison de se sentir heureux quel
travail
vous avez devant vous un des plus grands
vont loger du monde un horloger du à
fabriquer des horloges des pendules et
démontrent non non j'ai fait des coucous
c'est extraordinaire que j'aimais
raconte-nous vie comme moussa s'est
passé et bien voilà vous connaissez mon
cousin théodule qui comme chacun sait
est d'origine suisse
je ne savais pas qu'il y avait des
kazemi russe en suisse où moi non plus
les journaux n'ont jamais parlé a bien
évidemment ils ont quitté la suisse
il y à déjà 5 millions d'années pourrait
me qaïs id envie aux enfants mais c'est
à cause de cette origine qu'ils ont
gardé une grande passion pour les
montres et les pendules
enfin casimir c'est impossible il est
vrai que les horloges et les montres
suisses sont de grande qualité etc
l'horlogerie suisse est célèbre mais il
ya 5 millions d'années il n'y avait pas
de montre je sais et non parce que les
casimir une suisse sont d'une grande
exactitude donc
cousin théodule est devenu relogés voilà
et il a fait ces derniers jours une
commande énorme
alors il m'a chargé de l'aider à faire
des coucous oui vous savez les cours ce
sont ces ses pendules qui imite toutes
les heures le champ du du chant du
coucou ah oui c'est ça c'est ça qui
m'inquiète que tu viens de fabriquer
toute une série d'horloge et tu ne te
souviens même pas du chant du coucou
mais non françois tout s'est très bien
passé
le facteur a même déjà livrer le colis
alors attention attention je lis bon
soit vous cela vous êtes là guidé mois
seulement jusqu'au bout mais c'est un
risque que je puisse poser ce police
allaient bouger
attention attention c'est très fragile
ce sont des gens le suisse un tout
récent des fonds ou faut passer par
l'egypte surtout que j'ai dû faire
l'aller-retour en important 1
le destinataire n'a pas voulu pas voulu
je suis réputé ce sont peut-être des
coucous résilient
il n'avait pas l'air content il les a
tous ses marchés
et puis il m'a dit de les renvoyer à
l'expéditeur et il m'a même remis une
lettre pour toi casimiri y être pour moi
sic
j'adore recevoir des lettres de sa
maison rien qu'à voir la tête qu'il
faisait en l'écrivant un sens à main au
tremblay de colère oh là là c'est
magique rien
j'espère que tu arrivera quand même à la
lire un casimir bombay avec tout ça moi
mes amis j'ai peu dur pendant ma tournée
allez bon c'est tellement mal écrit
qu'il n'arrive pas à lire un mot pas
seulement un soutien merci monsieur
kazimiya
c'est bien pour moi mais bien sûr
puisque la lettre est adressée
tétouan casimir laisse le continuer je
reprends monsieur casimir je crois que
vous vous moquez du monde
on exagère en tout cas il a l'air
vraiment furieux vous n'avez expédié un
carton de coucou j'en ai écouté la
moitié j'ai entendu des tas de cris
d'animaux mais pas un seul coup
ah non là il exagère vraiment et
pourquoi tu dis ça parce que dans tous
les coups
je suis sûr qu'il y en a au moins qui
imite le coucou montres et horloges
casimir
on va te dire s'il y en a une qui a le
bon champ du coup couperin d'accord je
voulais sortir moi même parce que c'est
très fragile et si nous appelons les
enfants et bien sûr ils vont nous aider
vous venez me cédric essiminy
les enfants les enfants venez venez vite
sur casimir s'écrouler de cris d'animaux
pour ces horloges
il ne se souvenait pas du chant du
coucou alors vous allez l'aider à lui
dire quel est l'animal qu'on entend dans
chacune de ces horloges c'est d'accord
et bien casimir mon premier horloge
d'accord raffi le premier coup
umut la cigale c'est une cigale lors
très bien c'est pas un coucou sinon pas
du tout kazim est bon alors attendez
voir les douzièmes horloge écoutez bien
voilà frédéric c'est le chant du coq se
soumet pas encore une autre génération
suivante tu vois que tout le monde a
répondu c'est moi vous êtes jeudi les
enfants vous ne répondez pas tout de
suite pour que nos amis chez eux et le
temps de chercher aussi à en revendre
les arbres au contrôle de 1 million à
lyon c'est le rugissement du lion ont
rapidement
j'espère que nos aînés jersey ont trouvé
voilà celui là encore un autre
[Musique]
oui c'est un singe est bien possible oui
oui celui là fait possible a encore eu
notamment les joints la mire pas celle
là
écoute c'est une chèvre
ils ont tous répondu et centrait fort le
bêlement d'une chèvre ils nous trouvent
aujourd'hui relate voilà c'est pas une
vache beaucoup et l'âne c'est un âne
frédéric c'est un âne qui braie y en a
d'autres casinos c'est l'anarchie chez
vous les enfants c'est à cochons
accrochons qui grognent
j'en ai encore target ont jamais encore
une horloge celle ci est bénéfique
[Musique]
c'est le meuglement de la vache rang en
décidément n'a pas de chance ça ne
trouvent à leur niveau
j'en ai encore humain le cerveau ce
n'est pas un coucou ça mais oui c'est un
média citoyen et le celui là n'était pas
un coucou écoute pourquoi ça me
paraissait tellement facile c'est comme
certains exercices à l'école la réponse
paraît trop facile on croit qu'ils un
piège et on donne une mauvaise réponse
et tu vas être obligé d'en refaire tout
et coucou non pas question
ton client alors fais bien mon client je
vais lui renvoyer son colis avec une
nouvelle facture et je veux dire elle
veuillez trouver ci joint un coucou
cheval à coucou cochon un coucou chèvres
et cetera jusqu'à un coucou co voilà